Hello everyone, my name is Wojtek Kalicinski.
This is the Android Tool Time for everyone.
New features in Android Studio 2.3
Following the full-featured Android Studio 2.2
We released Android Studio 2.3 to start a new year
The new version has many improvements and fixes existing components
And bring some exciting new features
The first thing I want to mention
Is the revision of the Instant Run user interface.
We follow the developer’s advice
Now give you two buttons
Run - you will be used to provision and launch the application
Apply Changes - for any subsequent code
Or resource modification
This uses Instant Run to quickly update a running application
Hot plugging, warm plugging and cold plugging now require a device
Or run the simulator above Lollipop
If you happen to encounter any unexpected problems
You can use the Run button again at any time.
Force a restart of the application
Speaking of speeding up the build time of Android Gradle plug-in 2.3
Now we are by default
Enable build cache
Build the cache is a shared directory on your machine
Where is the library extracted and compiled
And used for all projects
Make incremental or full builds faster
In this version of Android Studio
We are in product synchronization and Gradle integration
Also made some general performance improvements
And go to Gradle version 3.3
The ID itself also brings new features to IntelliJ 2016.2
Such as the new Inspections Tool window
Maintenance notice, Java editor
Bread crumbs, etc.
The layout editor also has some updates
In the panel window, now we show
Widget preview and support sorting and filtering by name
Property Detector on the right
Now you can add the most commonly used properties
Go to Favorites to give you quick access to the overview page
Finally, the visual editor has a brand new control
Refined visual effects with constrained layout editing
Includes brand new icons
An easier way to add a benchmark
Two major functions that support constraint layout
Link and scale
Use the Android Studio template
When creating a new project
The default state now is constraint layout
Go ahead, VectorDrawable import dialog
There is also a small but demanding upgrade
Now you can search the Material icon directory by name.
This is easy
Find what you need
For raster images we added WebP support in the ID
WebP is an image compression format which was developed by Google.
Can be used to replace JPEG or PNG images
Same quality but smaller file size
Now you can convert images directly from the IDE to WebP
Just right click on the file or folder
Select "Convert to WebP"
WebP support varies greatly on different Android versions
We also added a Lint check
View the content of the image
If they are not compatible with the min SDK version in the project
Will issue a warning
Next, we have App Links Assistant
It will guide you
Add application link support to your app
This includes creating an intent filter for the URL.
Modify the activity code to handle these intents
And generate a Digital Asset Links document for your website.
For the fans of Lint, we also have some new or updated Lint
Now we support additional comments
Such as restricted and visible tests
Lint report, HTML document
There are also material design and syntax highlighting
Maximum addition is Lint baseline support
Enables you to save the currently known Lint error
And ignore it for future builds
Enable you to process step by step
Technical liabilities in the project
At the same time, it also has the advantage of
Tell you what you might introduce
Any new warnings and errors
As for SDK Tools, we recently added an SDK manager.
A command line interface named SDK Manager
You can use it to install or update automatically.
SDK components, such as scripts or CI servers
The last version of Android Studio
Espresso test recorder
There are also some improvements, which are now more stable.
You can use it to add Espresso UI
Test to the application
If you have any questions about the new version
Or want to get the latest information and tips about Android Studio
Please pay attention to our Twitter
Thanks for watching
Click here to watch more Android Studio videos